In Leo Tolstoy novel the death of Ivan Illich.
Ivan is mounting a step ladder to hang some drapes when he slips and Bang
Society against the window frame.
The injury does not seem serious,
but his health a slowly deteriorates more and more.
Until Ivan Ilitch realizes that he is going to die,
we're all going to die.
That is the truth that we all know,
but we knew it in a very abstract way.
We knew it in the same way.
We know that the earth rotates on an axis.
We know it in a way that has no effect on our day to day lives.
It is not until death has brought to the forefront of our attention that it
becomes an unavoidable reality.
Socrates was very concerned with the moral complacency he saw in his fellow
Athenian citizens.
He watched as they live their lives in a selfish,
unreflective Hayes.
His solution was to act as a moral gadfly,
stinging his fellow citizens and to self-examination.
Socrates stood in the marketplace daily,
forcing anyone he encounter to reflect on their lives,
beliefs and motivations.
Socrates is trying to make himself and others realize in the clearest possible
way how much our lives are geared towards self deceptive and self destructive
behavior.
He wanted us to know this like Ivan knew he was going to die after the accident.
This led to was development of a Linkous,
an intense form of dialog we now refer to as the Socratic method
in ancient Greece.
The temple of Apollo was home to the Pythia,
also known as the Oracle at Delphi who is believed to have a direct line of
contact with the gods.
If you're in the oracle business,
it is smart to word your prophecies as vaguely as possible.
You want your words to sound profound without committing yourself to any direct
answer.
Because of this,
when his friends traveled to the temple of Apollo and asked the Pythia,
is there anyone wiser than Socrates,
the must have been surprised to hear there is no human being wiser than
Socrates.
When this news reached Socrates ears,
he fought the gods.
Must've made a mistake since he knew very well that he was not wise,
but he also knew the gods do not make mistakes.
This became a grand mystery and it launched him on his lifelong quest.
He sought out every person who made claims to wisdom.
He would converse with them,
ask them questions,
and try to uncover if indeed there were as wise as they claimed.
The most notable of these interactions were with two groups of thinkers,
the natural philosophers and the sophists.
We will use the first natural philosopher Bailey's as an example for this
viewpoints.
Instead of attempting to explain the world around him through mythology,
dailies tried to explain natural phenomenon by theories and hypotheses.
Dailies believed that the originating principle of nature and the essence of was
a single material substance.
Water on the surface.
We know this is not true,
but it is the change in the way of thinking that is important.
Here they lived in Greece,
which is surrounded by water.
Water falls from the sky and allows us to live,
dig into the earth and we find water.
Every living creature requires water.
It is a very plausible idea.
One could reach the reasoning and observing the world around them.
It is very different from the type of thinking you would find from an oracle who
would explain every natural phenomenon through the will of the gods.
The main takeaway is that families and the natural philosophers after him,
we're using rational reflection and observation and attempts to find some
underlying structure to reality.
Socrates became impressed by thinkers like these,
but he ultimately rejects it.
They have wisdom.
He felt that this type of knowledge isn't wisdom because it doesn't enable you
to become a good person.
It has no existential relevance.
It does not instruct us on how to overcome the self destructive and self
deceptive behavior.
Socrates felt was so prominent in Athens.
Socrates enjoys rational knowledge as much as the next guy,
but he doesn't find wisdom or the capacity for self transcendence within it.
The second group he encountered where the Sophos mini sophos specialize in the
use of rhetoric,
which is the art of using speech to enhance the ability to convince and persuade
a skill that had become incredibly important in the democracy of Athens.
To understand why Socrates ultimately rejected the ideals of the Sophos.
We will analyze the philosopher Harry Frankfurt's essay on bullshit.
Frankfurt says that there is a fundamental difference between bullshitting and
lying.
The liar tries to get you to believe something is true when it is not.
They are relying on the fact that you want to know the truth and they use your
commitment to truth as a means of deception.
The bullshit artists does something different.
They direct your attention in a way that makes you no longer care about whether
something is true or false.
The bullshit artists is no longer concerned with truth,
but with salience,
salience is how things stand out to us.
We can bullshit ourselves because we can direct our attention.
So certain things become more salient.
With the rhetoric of the Sophos,
I can make something relevant to you without you having to believe or even care
if it is true.
Socrates felt that through the practice of the Sophos salients and what people
find relevant were being separated from truth.
What grabs people's attention is no longer leading them to what is true and
Socrates felt that there was something deeply deceptive and immoral about this
practice.
Socrates believe the natural philosophers provided truth without relevance and
the Sophos provided relevance without truth was Socrates wanted was both.
He wanted a rational pursuit of truth that has transformative relevance to the
individual.
He was after the type of truth that can make you wise.
He wanted what grabs our attention to also track what is truthful and this is
why he developed his practice of a Linkous.
He would sit in the marketplace for hours and ask everyone he encountered
questions which seemed innocuous at first,
but at each answer he would dig deeper and deeper into why they do the things
they do.
Until the person reaches a state of APP Poria or a point in which they are
forced to step back and say,
I don't know.
Socrates wants to shock us out of our day to day thinking.
He wants us to realize that the way we are living is perfectly set up for
bullshit and self deception because the things that motivate and attract us
massively outstrips our understanding of them.
This discourse of his was disruptive to many and eventually led him to be
arrested on charges of rejecting the gods of the state and corrupting the youth
of Athens at his trial.
Socrates is basically told that if he stops philosophizing in this way,
he will be able to live,
which led to his now famous claim that the unexamined life is not worth living.
If we do not think and become aware of our self deceptive tendencies,
then we are trapped in the mundane world and remain incapable of transcending
our self destructive behavior.
He knows this to be true and is willing to die for that truth.
Unlike the natural philosophers,
he's not making any claims about the natural world.
He's making a claim about our individual experience and how each of us can live
a more meaningful life.
Socrates comes to the realization that the gods were right,
that he was the wisest human being.
Only because he knows that he knows nothing.
Most of us know that we don't know a lot,
but we know it in a way that Ivan Ilitch knew he was going to die before the
accident.
We don't know it as a constant and ever present reality.
Socrates claimed to be the midwife of new ideas because while this type of
thinking was a difficult labor,
if one is willing to pass through it,
they can give birth to a new way of being,
and the court of Athens,
after Socrates is found guilty,
each side gets to suggest their own punishment.
The accusers proposed the death penalty,
but Socrates suggests something different.
He says that because this life of philosophy has kept him impoverished and cost
him so much time and energy in service of other people,
that he should not receive a punishment,
but the reward of free housing and food so he can do even more service to Athens
with his philosophy,
the court,
Moses Silver,
and decides,
okay,
in doing this,
Socrates was leaving the people of Athens.
The one final lesson.
Since we cannot know what awaits us after this life,
we have no way of knowing if it is better or worse than what we were
experiencing now.
And if that is the case,
once you not compromise integrity
in fear of death,
because death is nothing to be feed.